I liked fat Thor me too loved him I did
not have the negative reaction that
other people that I felt like there was
a moment where they were trying to push
it a little too hard when they were like
planning the time heist and he was
talking about it was a little drawn-out
you know trying to get a little bit more
humor from it I think that was the only
moment that I had like good worthy I
loved him not happy to lose all the
weight to be worthy fat Thor hi guys I'm
Greg Alva I'm Katrina Katrina Alicia
follow her on social media as well on
the fan Theory TV channel where she
covers Doctor Who
she does who who do you do doctor food
that's our new clothes
keep that in mind well clearly we liked
Avengers end game and I want her to
check out this video from one of my
favorite channels looper end game
director's reveal how Chris Hemsworth
reacted a fat doors new looking Avengers
and game has been a hot topic amongst
Marvel fans since the moment the film
dropped in theaters people have been
bickering back and forth over whether to
god of thunder gaining a noticeable
amount of weight that his hair grow long
as beard gets scraggly and settling into
a routine of beard chips and video games
was a cheap attempt at laughs or an
accurate depiction of the effects trauma
and grief can have on a person amongst
oldest chatlian person that remained
pretty quiet about that Thor and endgame
is Thor himself famously fit actor Chris
Hemsworth thanks to endgame directors
Joe and Anthony Russo
we know how Hemsworth reacted to the
news that his hammer swinging hero
character would sport a different
physique in the film looking at a recent
interview with Sirius XM the russo
shared that Hemsworth was totally on
board for chubby Thor and was ready to
take the character in the new direction
mr. Russo put Hemsworth is up for
anything he likes to take risks it's a
nice way of putting it
you gave him birth a call to discuss
where Thor's personal journey would go
and endgame and how his character arc
would wrap up a while before any game in
its predecessor infinity war which was
shot back-to-back began filming meaning
the Russos and Hemsworth knew well in
advance what Thor would look feel and
act by selling quite a gobbler movie
Anthony Russo said before the script was
ready when he called him to pitch the
character arc he was either still
finishing or had just finished Ragnarok
but he was still energized by the work
he had done with taiko ytt in that movie
in terms of coming up with the comedic
and irreverent Thor Anthony's brother
Joe finished the thought saying and we
were like wait until you hear what we've
got for you Hemsworth couldn't open up
much about Thor an endgame or offer
explicit details about the hero's
transformation until the movie premiered
in theaters in late April but he did for
a tiny tease to USA Today ahead of the
Picts debut the Aussie actor told the
outlet that he in the Russos had
multiple in-depth talks regarding Thor's
change from the god of thunder with
lightning coursing through his veins to
his self conscious guy that his fellow
Avenger Steve's has cheese ways flowing
through that circumstance we've had to
keep mum about the specifics at that
time though he did explain that he quote
wanted to do something different and
push Thor to these limits in endgame
he told USA Today the Russos were on
board and we sat for many hours and days
and discussed kind of how far we could
push it and what we could do different
back door certainly is different to any
other iteration of the hero fans have
seen in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
before it was a bold move on the part of
Emsworth and the Russo brothers and
definitely caused a rift in the Marvel
fandom but it's evident there was no ill
intent behind a decision rather it
sounds like the endgame team wanted to
depict Thor in a brand new light while
making a point about how everyone
handles feelings of grief and guilt in
their own ways and how there isn't just
one right way to be a hero one of the
most prominent takeaways from fat Thor
in the film is that he never underwent a
fat bit transformation in order to boost
his confidence or to prove to love that
summon is hammer Mjolnir and fight the
brutal battle against
at the end of endgame while keeping on
the extra pounds he gained over the five
years post snap he may not look the way
he used to but he's just as powerful an
important message to send to audiences
like Avengers end games explains we
leave him in that state at the end of
the movie even though he's emotionally
resolved we fix his problem and it's not
his weight I think he is the ideal Thor
at the end of the movie and he's
carrying some weight and this Anthony
Russo stated in a recent interview we
find fat Thor as inspiring as any
version of Thor appears positioned to
make a return in the MCU with guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 given where he wound
up at the end of endgame
the merciless did note in their SiriusXM
interview that it's ultimately up to
director James Gunn whether Thor plays a
part in the upcoming film but if he does
it seems his big belly and bushy beard
might be coming back to check out one of
our newest subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt if you miss a
single one subscribe to looper guys my
one nitpick about this whole fat the
word to boggle is that we call him fat
Thor if Chris Hemsworth actually gained
weight for the role we would not call
him fat Thor he was actually really
overweight it would be so insulting to
call him fat Thor it's not like fat
shaming at that point that's just like
the tiniest nitpick to me is just more
humorous the fact that we can call them
fat Thor you think I do think I have
thoughts that's a tough like line to
walk so I feel like these days people
are also trying to make the word fat not
seem like such a bad word are they yeah
no that was happening yeah I thought we
were not trying to fat shame
like why is like if someone is fat is it
a dirty word and like I know there are
people who are trying to like embrace
embrace it okay you know it's an
interesting line that's being walked so
when it comes to the political
correctness of these things look what
I've learned is I gotta listen to women
more so if you're giving me advice to my
man brain then fine fat for it is fat
ass Thor fat [ __ ] door
no that's not take it too far it's okay
damn it forgiven sorry I thought I was
getting somewhere in terms of character
this always made sense to me I was never
bothered by it I've gone through some
pretty hardships in my life and
dealing with you know the loss of some
people definitely led to a lot of weight
gain in my life and it wasn't until like
two years ago - lost like 30-something
pounds but I gained that wafer and I had
it for a long time you know to me I'm
like that's a part of grief and I think
it to apply it to Thor would actually
make the most sense out of someone who
for a thousand plus years has never lost
a battle and lost the jury yeah never
lost in his life and he just lost for
the first time of course he's gonna be
depressed of course it's gonna drink
himself into a stupor I thought that was
the most real thing they could have done
with his character and I love the the
fact that he didn't lose the weight by
the end of the movie that was my I was
worried
at one point when they did present fat
Thor in the movie I got a little worried
in my head is there gonna be this whole
montage moment of him working out and
like and there wasn't and I was like yes
I thought it when he got in the ER and
and I Stormbreaker
okay he's gonna be like suddenly really
fit you know when the lightning strikes
me I'm like oh no they kept the weight
that was cool Choki and still had the
scrabbles and just a breeze like a
Viking look so good I loved it and also
Chris Hemsworth performance really
helped save it if thor ragnarok had not
come out and then they did this it would
not have worked they were in a ward
because it wouldn't have had the comedic
Thor this would have been way too
jarring but and he loved Ragnarok so
much Chinese made such good working it
to you like so many what are the odds
people I think Chris Hemsworth in
general has just shaped his whole image
yes from stoic serious pretty man to god
this guy is so beautiful but also
hilarious
yes hilarious very still relatable in a
sense to me I'm like ah the fact that
you did fat Thor makes me feel really
fat fat ass alcoholic Thor I loved
that's the best way to sum him up well I
like you were saying I've also dealt
with grief and struggle and my password
like there was a point in time where I
had weight on and that just that's how
it happens like grieving and all of
these things have you lost it yeah okay
mm-hmm I was like four years ago but you
know it was before I moved out here yeah
yeah sure okay he's so nervous to talk
about a woman's weight right now on
camera skinny skinny Katrina yep
seriously I love that aspect of the
movie and I do know people who didn't
like it they thought it was like a cheap
shot at humor I mean sure it's funny
like they present it in a funny way but
I think there's other layers to it more
layers than just a cheap shot at humor
in my opinion they made humor out of it
but it's the same way I felt about
professor Hulk of like they made a humor
out of it especially upon the
introduction in early on after a while
it's not just like it's so funny every
time you see hope that way and it's the
same thing with Thor's like it's not a
it's so funny every time he's ether it's
just part of the cat's who they are it's
their character and it makes sense to me
before we wrap this video up I like to
give a patient a shot to a man named
Taylor Bentley secretly I'd like to get
to know our patrons Taylor was a man I
was really getting to know strongly for
many months and then he got a girlfriend
who was apparently way out of his league
I haven't heard from him since he stayed
pledge which is the way people should
operate at our patreon I'm just assuming
that you probably came a fat Thor
yourself probably gained all that date
weight not too comfortable comfy
they probably spilled a bunch of you
know chilli cheese sauce on the keyboard
see it couldn't tie back to me I get it
man I've gained eight weight - I've been
there buddy just get as fat as you want
and if she still loves you she's
definitely lower her standards is that
where you're going yeah subscribe the
rejects click that notification bell
follow Katrina on social media I'm fan
Theory TV catch you guys soon that's a
lot about your stuff